so guys once again back to some 400
videos that we're going to be continuing
off from where we left off you know
yesterday's video when we talked about
the leveling up fast now we're going to
be talking about getting your gear
because if you have a high level and
high gear you're practically unstoppable
now one of the few things I did look at
as I was looking at some suggestions on
some tips from high level players and
this one was from a reddit user known as
Starscream so thank you Starscream for
this he says the gear impact is much
greater a prestige one and again a
prestige 3 as well I only made it to
prestige one on my server but I am fully
upgraded gear wise to my current extent
I hear a prestige 3 you will get heroic
or purple gear which would mean start
saving again a prestige to it is to
purge at stage or a prestige 3 basically
what he's meaning is that at level 1 all
the way up to prestige 1 on your hero do
not spend any money on premium packs if
you do that's ok you just don't do it
again
one of the reasons for that is because
you don't do none of the blue gear drops
at prestige 1 so like I said before
don't start anything or don't spend
anything until prestige 1 or reputation
1 start spending an ax soon as your
reputation 1 start spending all of your
stuff on premium tax get the blue gear
as soon as you hear prestige 2 save and
then as soon as you hit reputation 3
start spending to get the purple gear
now Ubisoft hasn't said anything if
there's anything higher than purple like
if there's gold or anything higher
no-one's founded it yet but there's kind
of a high chance seeing it purple is the
highest gear and that's a reputation 3
and there's 30 reputations for each hero
I'm assuming there's going to be more
but as of right now that's all we know
so like it so just a quick recap do not
spend any of your steel at ret the air
reputation 2 and level and then from
level 1 only at prestige 1 or reputation
1 or at reputation 3 are the only two
places you should start spending steel
because then you will get the higher
level gear quicker
instead of
finding steel during those other two
levels and then just getting a bunch of
white gear anyway guys it's going to be
it that's basically the part two to
yesterday's video I hope you all did
enjoy that like I said just like the
videos we did enjoy comment what is your
gear rating at or what level are you
however once again how are you enjoying
this game other than that guys subscribe
if you're new though it's always very
appreciated but a I'll see you guys
later in the next video and a peace out